hey guys before we begin the vlog I just
wanted to say a huge huge thank you to
every single one of you that watched and
commented and reached out to me based
off of the last video when I was talking
about my dad you guys have been
unbelievably supportive and loving and I
just want to really thank you guys you
guys have really brought my spirits up
and I just love you guys
so enjoy the blog good morning the most
since we started this home buying
process because the fun is part of it
all is we'll begin to pick on the stuff
but yeah right now we're on our way for
some really odd reason even though
really excited emotions I'm also really
anxious like I'm feeling feeling my
anxiety kicking in I don't know I think
I know why it's such a big decision it's
a decision that the decisions that we're
making today who live with us for the
next however many years that we had this
house yet and it's true you nailed it
baby
we're both really afraid of making
decisions like being wrong we're really
afraid of being wrong so maybe that's
what it is
like I'm just
I think most people hate to hear funky I
don't know because most people are just
like I don't know I like this and I want
to go with this so we're gonna do this
and I'm like huh
that's really good that you know
yourself that well that you know what
you want like I said in the other video
that we're talking about our home that I
I have been looking at Pinterest and I
collected some inspo photos so that's
gonna help guide our decision-making
does make it a little bit less scary but
yeah I mean well we can sell our home in
the future
cuz it okay so one of my fears that I'm
really experiencing right now is the
fact that I don't want to take something
that is clearly like a trench so if you
look at homes built in like the early
2000 they have that really yellow like
bright colored wood and that is just
very of that time and then if you look
at even older homes like in the 90s or
or 80s it's like really dark dark wood
like like a really red wood telling your
dark red wood oh what's the color now we
notice that there's a
there's a trend now in terms of what and
we're only talking about one here the
trend now it's like a light grayish but
like the contrast is really up high so
you can see the dark lines in the wood
the wood grain so that's a trend right
now which that's something I really
don't want anyway I don't really I mean
it does look good but not for my house
like I don't want that I kind of want to
go with something more timeless or at
least what I think could be timeless
because it's really hard to determine
what can last like like glass the test
of time so that's something that I'm
really stressed out about and I'm trying
not to be stressed out about because I
remember expressing these feelings with
Barton G over at their house and then
they were like well everything is a
trend like everything's gonna get to eat
it and I mean once it's dated you could
deal with it then like at least enjoy it
and then in the meantime so I'm like
yeah you guys are so right we get a lot
of my in Spokeo toes I feel like they're
gonna be very dated
eventually what are your exposure I know
what's what is your in scope stuff for
sure
it's white cabinets that's something I
really want is I okay my main thing for
the house is that I really wanted to be
feel bright and open and happy and
inviting and so what I've noticed in the
past trends is that there's a lot of
darker colors being used
and when I look at those photos like it
just makes me feel like yeah I could
make you feel cozy and like at home but
for me just makes me feel like like I
can't breathe like I mean I need natural
light I need it to be brighter like it
just it makes me feel depressed or like
I don't know I just that's not the look
that I really want to go for it and then
especially right now in our current home
there's a lot of dark material
everywhere so like in our kitchen for
example it's dark kitchen cabinets the
countertops are like granite and I hate
granite because you can't see but the
food chuckles in the countertops I
definitely really use your hands to see
if there's any don't think you missed
out but definitely not getting granite
because you can't see the dirtiness of
the countertops and then in our bedroom
there's not a lot of like natural light
that comes in especially in the vanity
area it's true me that our current place
right now that's built in the 1970s I
looked it up yeah thank you sixties even
yeah there just seems like the whole
further back you go the less important
windows work yeah they did not like the
natural light back then but yeah natural
light is very important and then so
that's the reason why I just want the
whole house to be
like a blank canvas almost where it's
like white countertops white cabinets
white walls of neutral light color floor
and then that's when I can bring in the
color with the accents and the decor and
stuff so that's my my game plan for the
house and then I know you're probably
wondering well what does case you have
to say about all this
what do you have to say a little good
that's mainly it sounds like I'm making
a lot of decisions if it's me driving
the car here that does not mean car the
ship driving whatever and I've given you
the airplane to fly completely I trust
you and I'll be the flight attendant a
form with the skirt and everything oh
you have really good taste and like it's
like I have my own thoughts too and I
got be like yeah I think it should be
like this like this like this and then
you were like not why I think you should
be like this this and this and I'm like
oh my god you just totally fresh from I
had in my head I'm like ever mind I
won't say anything about why ugh no no
it doesn't suck those I think it's great
like you just have a better idea of what
you want you to have the vision of it's
better though cause everything's
subjective
I don't know okay so objective-c I agree
with everything you say that cutting
everything comes out your mouth I'm like
that's bull Thanks
honestly like because this is our home I
would like for it I would love for it to
be a collaborative like effort but
because I know you struggle with the
station and I and then plus like you're
saying yeah you trust me and everything
and I don't know like it would be nice
to have your input to the room just
while you're talking
does that feel weird being like like I'm
the showrunner
in our home you know no I don't care me
ll be the showrunner in other areas of
our lives I feel like and you know
creating the house it's just one little
facet to the full life that we live but
but for me like it's also kind of like I
know the ideas that I have in my head
and like the colors that I would
generally pick are going to be dark
colors like all the cars I've ever
bought for a food for myself I've always
been dark colored cars and stuff like
that and I give you the insides of the
car like aside from this one like
they've always been dark interiors as
well and like it's what you like
thinking dark dark colors because I
remember the editing room too and the
Jay Kalfas is all black yeah exactly
that and that's my problem like my might
if I'm left my own thoughts I just want
everything dark for some reason but it
has a it has a psychological effect on
you though if you're surrounded by dark
things all the time and
I think it makes me feel more dread and
stuff and until you Thunder into my life
you kind of like you know help me
reinvent my wardrobe you know things
that I'm around at the rooms I'm in or
more vibrant and like lighter and color
and then like your your Tesla with the
white leather of life oh my god like
going fighter is so much better
sometimes I'm like and like it just
makes you feel happier and like I don't
know I just it just like what that said
I'm like what my natural decisions and
my my inclinations and my comfort zone
is to go darker anyways I don't want
that though I want to combat that so I'm
like you know what it says you make the
decisions because everything that you've
done for me has made me feel a lot
better about myself and take it away
baby you know you're the one that taught
me about color psychology maybe they you
know all this already is I know because
I could feel my my attachment on my lips
but I mentioned this in my stories on my
Instagram stories but I'm sure you
notice I have these new attachments on
my teeth which look like I have clear
braces where I'm like kind of bothered
by it because I did not
no these were coming when I signed up to
get Invisalign she briefly mentioned it
like oh you're gonna get attachments
love I'm just like okay I don't know
what that means but sure I'm going to be
a Salesman she was like oh this is the
part that much we don't like I mean I
really don't remember it like I don't
remember thinking oh they're gonna glue
some stuff on top of my teeth or it's
gonna be like braces when I signed up
for this so when it came I'm like really
are you for real I got Invisalign so I
can discreetly straight my teeth again
because they shifted a lot after having
a broken treaty married for so many
years
and I was just been really bummed out
about it because I didn't know they're
gonna be in the front teeth to kiss on
the bottom I have them in the back so
these are neon that noticeable lemon
they're all across the front so when I
put the aligners and you could see what
I'll put them in and then you'll see the
difference because right now it doesn't
look that bad they almost look invisible
but then wait till I put my eyeliners
all right so this is what it looks like
then the aligners are put in so maybe
this is like really good lighting you
can't really see the shadows but yeah it
creates more of a shadow around the
attachment
and yeah but when I post it on Instagram
you guys were so freaking sweet you are
so sweet you're like who cares like
you're rocking that I'm like you look
great or you can't even see them and it
doesn't matter it's gonna be all worth
it once you're done with like aligning
your teeth and I'm like you guys are so
awesome you guys made me feel so much
better about having these things put in
because I was really starting to get
self-conscious about it where I'm like
dude this is why I didn't sign up forget
it for clear braces because I when I
first got braces on when I was like 21 I
got the clear braces so it's a good
clear bracket but you can still see that
you have braces because you have the
wire connecting the bracket and then the
rubber bands I would go around the the
wire to keep it in place those bands
would get discolored and they turn
yellow before my next appointment so if
you're ever considering clear braces and
you need to have rubber bands I really
really do not recommend it because it
makes your teeth like straight-up
yellow like it looks ugly so because I
had a girlfriend that ended up sending
me a DM on Instagram saying like hey
we're considering getting clear braces
for my daughter but we're also looking
into Invisalign so if you got these
brackets in any way or like these
attachments should we just go with the
clear braces and I'm like no don't go
through braces it makes your teeth turn
yellow it's really ugly at least with
the Invisalign I could remove the liner
and I could still floss normally and
they don't turn yellow
I would still recommend Invisalign or
like clear aligners because I know
there's other brands but I got
specifically Invisalign so in 28 more
weeks I should be done with this so yeah
at least you guys made me feel really
good having a month thank you I love you
[Music]
okay now we're heading over Design
Center gonna be there in 11 minutes and
we're already 16 minutes late
[Music]
what are you trying to decide on counter
- they're just gonna leave me
countertops one countered that here we
go with this it's nice it's a good combo
weird don't seem so hard right now I
think you're right this is the combo I
like it
it totally matches the info photo it
does oh we didn't even find out how much
is back plastic hauling a little bit
this looks that we can't just spend
everything
[Music]
I like that more yeah it sounds kind of
cool - yeah it's like it's dark it's
also kind of light no I'm just here what
color would you want to go for the
lighter color darker color so hard
because our cat scratched up our entire
rug or carpet but whatever same thing TV
I don't know with this kind of after
that what she calls it or with the loop
rug or with a cut rug or with the shag
rugs I don't know either way they're
gonna be destroying it
I like the flooring that we picked out
this between - which one
those are backsplash I like that one
leaning towards this the most but then
I'm looking at this one again
I think we should go with our son this
is the info is it this one more I think
it's that one but sitting here in real
life in person this one looks really
good too and I really like the texture
of this one all right we made all our
decisions I'm very proud of let's
high-five
all right so we'll show you what we
picked out so here we have our floor for
the downstairs and the stairs we decided
to go with the stairs and that was a
really hard decision whether or not
we're gonna carpet up our stairs if you
laminate this is a carpet we chose with
this color and we picked it because the
cats like to scratch the carpet and the
way it does design we feel like it'd be
really forgiving when the cats do decide
to scratch up the carpet exactly
we're doing a white cabinet we're doing
the teal backsplash with this beautiful
court that has like little sparkles it's
really pretty so this is for the kitchen
and then for our bathroom we're doing
this one which is also a court visited
yesterday courts and then the tile for
the bathroom
this silver tile and then we just better
go with the brushed nickel finish that's
opposed to the chrome yeah
crowing CFE that's it right oh we did
that we also did like stainless steel
appliances and then
I can't remember now we pick them
anything
my brain is fried so I got we got like a
double-sided mirrored door for our
wardrobe I mean yeah my brains right -
for for the walk-in closet there's a
double-sided mirror thing that and extra
cabinets in the laundry room yeah we got
a laundry room
Oh recessed lighting we did all the room
exciting
you remembered a lot yeah we made so
many good decisions I'm so happy and I'm
so proud and I'm so excited
oh we even picked grout let me show you
this I never thought I'd pick route and
this made me really laugh but we went
with a standard white grout for that
piece of chalk okay I can do math on a
chalkboard that's gonna go between
backsplash tile adult and see our house
I'm sorry plated oh my goodness I'm so
excited
[Music]
[Music]